hello and welcome to Rochford district
matters the magazine produced by the
council for its residence this is the
autumn 2012 edition english edition our
articles on council tax benefit changes
events around the district ways to beat
the burglar in the focus a new way to
have your say the first look at census
data grant funding and much more but
we'll begin with a thank you why don't
you Liza 64 district witnessed a piece
of history of the Olympic torch crossed
through Raley on its 70 day journey
around the country around 30,000 people
came to raly to see the torch and the
council would like to thank everyone for
their help in making it such a fantastic
occasion there are lots of photographs
of the day which are on our online
flippers stream and we also worked with
thousand YMCA to make a film documenting
the day which you can watch on our
YouTube channel you can find the photos
and video by visiting www.hp.com UK and
it's kicking on the seeker or YouTube
icon on the bottom left hand corner of
the page and this article is accompanied
by a wonderful photograph showing
raiding high street with the
torchbearers and the lots and lots of
those
does he silencing people
community news celebrating local carers
the 14 carries and families together
that is known as staffed marked carers
week 2012 with lots of different fun
events and activities for both adults
and young carers more than 30 families
supplanting to Twilight pampering
evenings and enjoy treatments including
rightly head massage hair styling and a
luxurious chocolate fountain the big
finale de Paris week was an awards
presentation to young carers where
families friends and other invited dish
or enjoyed a special aging at the rocks
for Community Learning Center desks
would join us by the new patron of
scalf's the right honourable mr. mark
France was empty the leader of roxxor
District Council Councillor Terry cut
wall and chairman of the council council
mrs. Jones Oxford the event celebrated
the achievements of young carers who
have almost successfully completed
courses of the help of staff including a
fluke John Ambulance essential Thursday
the ethics youth award a level to
influence safety in catering and the
YMCA arts awards a special presentation
was also made by Jess Angus and fill
your dell from the hull breach Cristiano
spiritual church of three hundred and
seventy-two pounds
so fortunate charisms families together
chairman of trustees mrs. do Lumley said
he even provided a wonderful opportunity
for young families and their families to
celebrate their achievements together
the counselor and the Member of
Parliament for the district learning
about the achievements of these young
people to make a difference for their
families every day who are supporting
carers with families together scoffs
provides support in a district for
adults and young carers in ray and watch
bird food specialist for young carers
are provided in rochford rainy and wet
waiting for those aged 8 to 18 years the
session has provides scale activities
information and access to training and
during school holidays mountains are
organized give some of our trips to what
pilot Park to enjoy ponder dipping
Scudders outdoor activity centre where
the children and young people enjoy the
wide range of water-based sports and
activities including jet skis there was
also a trip to the cinemas to state by
stage 4 in 3d there really was something
for everyone scarce in a for charity
providing services locally if you're
like more information about its terms if
ratio that sponsor or supports the worth
of the organization whose contact jackie
brown on 01 2687 418 double one or email
info at scoffs dot org UK or visit the
website www.skype.com stopped UK
everyone divided to come along to the
10th rae rodgers and district
association for voluntary service on
rafts health and well-being community
day the event takes place on friday the
first years of november between 10am and
2pm of the mill art student center of
running in lena rayleigh the day is free
for everyone and you can visit stands
representing a wide variety of local
organizations past years have seen
groups such as the Citizens Advice
Bureau ethics police took Johns
Ambulance the pension service of
Southeast ethics NHS in attendance the
other details of organizations that will
be represented on the day will be
released closer to the date keep an eye
out for posters for the event on your
local parish noticeboards wraps also
runs a busy Volunteer Center where you
can find out more about how to help your
local community likewise if you are an
organization offering a service to the
local community and would like to be
added to the community directory or
receive advice on funding Raths can help
so for more information call Oh 1268
double 727 96 or email rafts which is
double our abs at rascals ok
the rockford own really Citizens Advice
Bureau has been given top marks by
auditors that advice and help it offers
to residents every three years each
citizens are five bureau in the country
undergoes of rigorous audit to ensure it
reaches the high standards required by
Citizens Advice their umbrella
organization and the advice services
Alliance quality mark the independent
test for quality of ice is designed to
ensure clients receive our high quality
service on issues such as dead benefits
housing employment and other aspects of
daily living The Rock's new enrollees
see Avery underwent it audit in May and
was judged to provide very precise the
highest awards at the advice services
Alliance can make the citizens of fire
service helps people resolve their legal
money and other problems by providing
free confidential independent and
impartial advice and information and by
influencing policy makers helping
prevent problems for everyone initial
assessments are available via the
telephone on 08 double 44 double 70 80
83 books appointments are available
outside the advertised opening hours and
details of opening hours can be found at
www.rockymountainatvmc.com
the stunning Railly one mill has just
hosted its 100th celebration Neil and
Haley Clary became the 100th couple to
celebrate when they married at the
popular venue the new mr. and mrs. Carey
said we chose the rayleigh windmill for
our wedding as it's a unique and
intimate venue and a lovely place to
revisit in the future we've had such a
beautiful day thank you to all the staff
at the window since becoming licensed
for weddings civil ceremonies and
celebrations the windmill has become a
popular place to hold a special event
the windmill is more than 200 years old
and has been sympathetically refurbished
to offer a unique venue for civil
wedding civil partnerships naming
ceremonies or renewal of vows the
seating for up to 20 guests the windmill
offers an intimate venue for your
celebration several packages are
available and the dedicated event
coordinator will ensure that your
special day runs perfectly call 0170
2318 120 to find out more and there's a
special offer to go inside with the
100th celebration at the windmill the
council is offering a twenty-five
percent discount for the next ten civil
ceremonies books at braly windmill the
bookings will be entered into a draw
with the winner receiving a one hundred
percent discount on there
terms and conditions apply
sporting heroes across Rochford and
castle point are looking forward to a
garlic evening later this month at the
rochester description castle point
sports award sponsored by virgin active
the fish sports awards i set to be even
bigger and better than ever before
because for the first time the drudges
have had to pick winners from across
Rochford and castle point it's the first
time rochford District Council active
rocks first title point Borough Council
and active castle point have joined
together to search for the cream of the
area's sporting talents the judging
panel were inundated with entries and
the shortlisted finalists have been
invited to a garner ceremony at Raley
Mills arts & Events Center where the
guest of honor will be Olympic badminton
silver medalist Gail ends MBE this year
the judges have picked winners for the
awards in the following categories
sports personality of the year sponsored
by Wells legal solicitors and wells
legal homes disability sports
personality of the year sponsored by
waters and Stanton PLC young sports
personality of the year sponsored by
sultan delighted community and
educational trust sports club as a year
sponsored by sports therapy and
rehabilitation known as star services to
sport sponsored by the talkative funeral
care
and watch hidden castle point 2012
respect award sponsored by affinity 1777
and to find out more about your sports
club to benefit from the council's help
contact sports development officer mark
elders on 0170 2318 one-to-one or visit
www.flu.gov UK forward slash measure and
look out for the winners who will be
enough in the winter edition of RT m and
families has the chance to try out
sporting activities free as charged
after active Rockford an active
castlepoint community activity networks
secured funding of 10,000 pounds from
Sport England earlier this year the
retriever dental Castle Point family
games net family is try lots of
different activities ranging from
traditional sports like table tennis and
badminton to others they may not have
tried before like fencing each course
runs for six weeks and for further
information on the sessions please call
Oh 17 / 23 1812 one or email sport at
rockford dot dot dot uk' active Rockford
an active powerful point or community
activity networks that include
organizations that have a desire to
develop and promote for
and physical activity for the benefit of
their local area and essex shuffled
oxford art trail saturday the 27th of
october to set up a third of november
get ready for Oxford to transform into
an exhibition space with a force
rochford arts trail for world waits over
100 artists will be exhibiting at
artwork textiles ceramics and
photography here 35 venues around the
town the trail launches on stretched out
over the 27th is a huge day of art
activities including an arts and crafts
market workshops and music but to find
out more visit the website on
www.sec.gov docks UK forward slash art
trail where follow us on twitter at
watch this underscore are for the latest
updates local councils will be
responsible for designing and
implementing their own schemes to refine
help to people on a low income pay their
council tax currently the council
receives one hundred percent funding
from the government to cover the cost of
the count to tax benefits scheme from
8-12 2013 our grant will be reduced by a
ten percent which means we will have
around five hundred twenty thousand
pounds less to run our proposed new
scheme this reduction means we have some
difficult decisions to make about who
gets financial support and how much it
could mean people you pay no council tax
at the moment they have to pay some and
people who currently pay some may have
to pay more the government has said that
pensioners will be protected from any
reduction in support this means from
april 2013 the level of support we give
to our working age customers will have
to be less than we currently gives them
to create a system that is as fair as
possible we have put together a proposed
local county tech support scheme to read
about our proposed scheme and see how it
may affect you if it www k /l SC t SC in
our proposed scheme all council tax
benefits will be automatically
transferred to the new local council tax
support scheme from the first of april
2013 as part of the government's welfare
reforms from april 2013 working-age
people living in Council or
Association properties or see the amount
of Housing Benefit they get cut if
they're home in too big for their needs
you under occupation rules mean the
amount of rent used to calculate
someone's benefit will be reduced by a
full team percent if they have one
bedroom above their needs and
twenty-five percent if they had two or
more bedrooms above their needs under
the new rules the number of bedrooms
allowed before restrictions apply will
be one bedroom for a single person or
couple one bedroom for person over 16
one bedroom for two children of the same
sex under 16 one bedroom for choose two
children under 10 boys and girls are
expected to share and one bedroom is the
claimant or their partner needs an
overnight carrier to stay an extra
bedroom cannot be allowed for any other
reason for example because foster
children stays are couple sleep in
separate rooms because of illness
children come to stay with a divorced or
separated parents and because of a
disability the council is already
working with housing associations in the
district to identify claimants who will
be effective and we will be writing to
them with more information and advice if
you think you will be affected by this
change then contact revenues and
benefits all 0 1 702 318 1 9700 1702 318
198 or visit www watch Rosie ok
slash benefits if you would like to talk
about moving to a smaller home please
contact your Housing Association direct
don't forget that you can sign up for
paperless billing and receive your
council tax bills by email already
hundreds of people have signed up to
receive their bills from the revenues
and benefits came via email rather than
through the post the team are
responsible for producing printing and
posting thousands of council tax bills
and booklets every year by signing out
to paperless billing you will help
reduce our costs and carbon footprint
not only will signing up to receive your
future bills by email be good for the
environment it will also be convenient
for you and convenient for us signing up
couldn't be easier just visit w WR g
shook a forward slash paperless billing
fill in the form click Submit and we
will do the rest for you Rockford
district's budget survey we want your
views on what you consider are the
priority services of your local estate
council and how you think the available
budget should be spent your views will
be taken into account when the council
considers its future spending priorities
over the next few years watch the
district council like public bodies
across the nation is likely to have to
make further changes the way it works as
we deal with reductions in our funding
from central government following cuts
to our government grant of seventeen
percent in 2011-12 our grant for 2012-13
was cut by a further eleven percent
changes to the way local authorities are
funded mean that we do not yet know what
our funding for 2013-14 will be but like
the rest of the public sector we are
expecting further reductions as the
government tackles the public deficit
some of the trust decision was made over
the past few years were helped by the
feedback received from the budget survey
was carried out these have identified
what services were considered to be
particularly important and should be
protected from cups and which services
were seen as lower priority by residents
as the choices get harder each year the
council again wants to find out what's
important to you before councillors
decide where any further reductions will
have to be made we're looking for your
views about the district of the whole
based on your day-to-day experiences and
what you would like to see as the
priorities for services over the next
few years we'd like to know which
services are important to you and which
you consider low priority where we could
consider reducing the level of service
in order to save money
please remember that although the
council provides many services for
residents there are other public service
providers to such as the county council
the police and the primary care health
trust who are all responsible for
providing services in the district the
survey will also be available on the
website for online completion thank you
for taking the time to help councillor
Terry cut more leader rocks for district
council now where do we get our money
from well the district council has three
main sources of funding 3.9 million
pounds in Lane grant from central
government including the redistribution
of business rates 6.4 million from
council checks and 5.2 million from
other income for example fees and
charges for services we provide such as
planning and car park charges and who
spends the council tax as residents of
Rochford district you contribute to
funding council services through playing
council tax in addition to services
provided by watch the district council
we collect council tax on behalf of a
number of authorities and these are
Essex Police Authority 9% rocks from
District Council thirteen percent
if it's Fire Authority 4% town and
parish councils three percent and Essex
County Council 71 percent the survey
asks you to choose five services that
using are the most important and which
five are released important these are
the services collection of local taxes
cemeteries and churchyards community
support corporate management Railly
windmill democratic services development
management economic development
emergency planning environmental health
grounds maintenance highways
homelessness and rising leisure and
sports development licensing parking
parks and open spaces planning policy
public conveniences public health
recycling collection and disposal
revenues investigation Street cleansing
and Woodlands now it may be difficult
for some residents to complete the
survey on their own what the district
council has concerns that
if someone finds this difficult they can
call the council on Oh 17025 463 double
six and help will be available the
closing date for that survey is the
twenty-first of December 2012 those
Thursday November the 15th residents
across the rocks the district will have
the opportunity to vote for an elected
police and crime Commissioner PCC for
the whole of Essex local police
authorities in England and Wales are
being replaced by directly elected PCC
voted for by you the government believes
this will make the police more
accountable to the community and will
restore confidence and trust in them
follow most as police and crime
Commissioner elections on a domestic
thinks the next election will take place
on may 2016 and subsequently every four
years it is important that you take part
in the election and vote for who you
want to see take on a new role what
wouldn't you play some crime
Commissioner do the police and crime
Commissioner will be expected to cut
crime and hold the cheapest
unaccountable for the performance of
their force the Chief Constable will
retain this possibility for operational
matters and control and direction of
offices and self though the PCC will
have the power to attach the chief
comfortable if necessary the PCH they
will set the police and climb objectives
for their area in a five-year police
inclined plane in consultation with the
public and the Chief Constable the
police and crime Commissioner will also
set the annual police budget and preset
and must report annually on progress
against the objectives in the police and
crime plan the PCC themselves will be
held to account by a policeman Brian
panel comprising counselors from each
council in a county together the two
co-opted members the panel will
scrutinize the words of the PCC and
support them in their role telefunken
will work police and crime commissioners
will be elected by the supplementary
folks system so the way you cast your
vote is it different from the normal
council elections held each way how do I
complete my ballot paper you can cause
the first and second choice your
Minister templates for either be part of
a political party or standing as an
independent candidate you vote for your
first choice 28 by more slip cross in
the first choice column you vote for
your signature scent don't buy more fair
crossed in the second choice column it's
really Malta first choice your vote will
still be counted you can choose not to
mark a second short stint date however
if you only mark the second choice
translate your thoughts will not be
counted if you give the same candidate
your first answer
I mean the first choice will be counted
if the candidate receives more than half
of all the first 28 about it's very like
diddle immediately if this does not
happen the two candidates is the most
first choice votes goes through to a
second round all other candidates are
eliminated but there's different choices
but private of the top soon templates
are added to the totals for those two
candidates from the first round the
curve date of the highest combined total
of first and second choice votes or be
elected if the police and fire
Commission of the ethics the different
ways you provoked there are three ways
you can vote in the elections on
Thursday 15 to serve vendor in person
register closes can visit their local
polling station between 7am and 10pm
150th november this long polling day you
will be sent a poll cloud you can only
vote at the polling station on this cold
you do not need to take your poll card
give you to the polling station but
doing so will speed up the process by
post if you do not wish to or unable to
go to a polling station you can apply
for a postal vote to vote for a toast
you need to register as a person voted
before 5pm Wednesday search first of
October postal ballot papers will be
sent out around the first of no vendor
you should complete these then send of
back straight away so they arise before
10pm or a 15th of november in a song
feminine to complete the postal voting
statement with your signature and date
of birth first arriving off 10pm one
fifteenth of nerves in door will not be
counted if you don't leave enough time
to post your vote you may take it go
around to a polling station in the rocks
with district council area or a seven
a.m. to 10pm on the polling day by proxy
you can register for a proxy vote this
means you ask someone you trust to vote
on your behold for the tent stake you
wish to vote for all you need to do is
complete and sign a form and return it
to your local electoral registration
office before five pm on the 7th of
November 2012 if you have any questions
come with the election of helpline on
over 70 2318 187 here's the further out
more at www choose my TCC dot org dot u
K or call our 800 1 07 07 08 to all the
printed information
rochford is part of a partnership of six
councils across the south of the county
which is responsible for enforcing
parking restrictions on our streets the
partnership also deals with proposals
for new parking restrictions and decides
along with effective residents whether
new restrictions should be implemented
the final decision is based on a
consultation with residents and local
councillors a simple majority in favor
of a scheme means it is likely to go
ahead in parts of accounting control
over parking on residential streets is
achieved by a residence parking permit
scheme rather than the simple yellow
line controls that have been favored in
rochford typically on payment of a/c
perhaps about fifty pound per annum a
resident will be issued with a permit to
allow party in their street together
with vouchers to enable visitor parking
when required whilst there is a cluster
resident permit schemes are more
flexible than yellow line controls and
are effective at controlling commuter
parking the council is proposing to
convert existing yellow line controls to
the parking permit alternative but it
may be that residents in some streets
would prefer this option if that's the
case we'd like to hear from you any
requests received for an introduction of
a parking permit scheme will be
carefully considered and subject to
consultation with all residents in the
street and to reiterate no scheme will
be implemented unless there is a
majority in favor
you can make a request or provide your
comments by emailing transportation at
Rochford of dr. dan cox UK or in writing
through Transportation Department divx
sweet tour foxy road rail Essex SF 680
be ways to pay for parking new pay and
display parking machines were introduced
in all council car parks in October last
year to give motorists better value for
money and the variety of payment options
you can now pay to park in the district
by the following methods payment by
credit or debit card the ticket machines
allow motorists to pay using Chip and
PIN wave and pay the machines now accept
debit cards that have a chip cities
allowing contactless payment providing
motorists with a speedier transaction
for small payments without the need to
enter a pin payment by mobile phone all
the car parks display full details of
how to pay using your mobile phone this
method of payment gives you the option
of receiving a text message to remind
you when your ticket is due to expire
and if you want to crop up your parking
should you be delayed in returning to
your vehicle you can even download a pay
phone and pay parking up onto your
mobile phone by searching for them rose
boost mobile there is more information
on how to register and play using your
mobile phone on the council website
linnaeus cherishing all the scenes
operate linear charging when paying
using coins this means that if you don't
have the exact coinage and have to
overpay for your chosen terrace you will
receive any extra paid as time on your
ticket this is calculated relative to
the next time band and means motorists
receive better value for money full
details of the various cashless payment
options are available on the council
website www oxford WK or by calling 012
687 9860 6 or 7 98 608 now here's some
information about changes to bus passes
from the first of October this year if
you are applying for an older person or
disabled persons past cards for the
first time or looking to replace your
lost stolen or broken pass you will need
to apply to Essex County Council this is
the course there is now one centralized
system for processing bus pass
applications and replacement passes
applications should be completed in full
and toasted to ethics e mc2
yes bus Plus p.o.box to 12 waterlooville
to7 6z n application form of are
available for download at
www.cannainsider.com also request
assistance completing the form by
calling this number or you could collect
the form from your local library if you
already have a bus pass and it's soon
for renewal provided you're at the same
address a new bus pass will
automatically be sent to you however if
you've changed address you must inform
essex county council by emailing bus
pass dot team at essex guide staff dot
uk' or by calling 0845 200 oh 3 double
eight and please note the changes are to
the application process only and not to
the entitlement or service hours
elson about four small kids one adds the
old fire station in hopefully on a
second saturday of every month lots of
local produce source from X and honey to
seasonal fruits and vegetables tea and
coffee and cakes are available and it's
free admission for information or
contact 0170 2007 707 for breaking
traders indoor mold hit in the whole
bridge community center pool Lane SS 5
6pm on November the force between 1030am
and 230 p.m. a feast of natural produce
and home baked in 08 jams and chutneys
twice as much more with free parking
contacto 1702 to double 3 double for one
WR a hall will in west street oxford on
the first saturday of every month except
january between nine-thirty and 1230
p.m. admission is free contacto 17025
407 double too rarely high street market
is every wednesday between 8 am-2 p.m.
utilize fresh meat fish fruits
vegetables speciality breads cakes
cheese pies sweets and lots more besides
all market days detective pickup is in
the label at the crown pub and drop off
in the label at the clock wonderful wild
water sea is now open the RSPB wild
coast project is now officially open you
can explore the island of yourself and
spot some of the many different species
of thirds the project is encouraging or
joining with one of the many events
children Wallace's throughout the year
admission and parking is free the island
is open seven days a week during
daylight hours for more information
visit www.zpp
all docs UK /water see clubs societies
and events the roach art group annual
exhibition takes place on Saturday the
27th of October from ten a.m. to four
p.m. at some theresa's church hall
ashington road oxford and located to the
rear of the church and entry is free and
regular meetings are held on wednesday
evening between seven-thirty and 9 30
p.m. there is good lighting and
facilities and all the villages are
catered for a disc friendly club will
use a variety of media membership
inquiries from beginners and experienced
are always welcome and reasonable fees
applies in details on your test contact
christine on 0 1 702 586 double 360 John
on 079 double 326 3930 the Haven art
group meets weekly every tuesday from
130 to 330 p.m. at some marks tools that
marks field Rochford SS for one PT this
is a self-taught social art group with a
number of places available and all
abilities are welcome the cost is to
pound contact 0170 2 3 4 650 1 or 0 1
702 4673 28 the next whole bridge multi
arts and crafts show takes place on
October the 28th between 1030am and 3 30
p.m. this is held at whole bridge
community center in pools Lane SS 56 PA
and is a chance to enjoy a purchase
original work direct from artists in
craftsman the craft show takes place
every last monday of the month except
for december the second and admission is
free again for more information contact
0170 22 doubles three double for one
rayleigh age concern is are you
different more older people to attend a
majority stay luncheon club home cooked
fresh food is made on the premises and
transport to and from the venue can also
be arranged for a moderate cost
entertainment and social events are
regularly arranged this takes place five
days a week 52 weeks a year between
ten-thirty a.m. & 2pm at the Todman
Center in Castle Road Raley again for
more information contact Oh 1268 double
75 380 ambridge Memorial Hall is now
open and available to Hummer so 30
pounds per session morning afternoon
evening or all day seven days a week
it's suitable for various functions
including parties clubs and classes for
more information visit www x-info net /
Stanbridge parish council sports cubs
scuba diving and diver odyssey tuesday
and thursday evenings and saturday
afternoon in a various locations and you
can contact debbie
wood on Oh 17025 for 2759 or email
Debbie at dive or the sea and i'll spell
that div ii ody SS e a.net then there's
expert picks scuba every wednesday
evening at hasta las seven at the green
sward academy and hotly and you can
learn to scuba dive take part in a full
range of the PA di courses or just have
Derek diving contact 0170 to 395 395 or
email JP @ extra pics dr dot uk' then
we've got rarely leisure indoor bowls
club that's that rarely leisure centre
priory chase is a 69 n s new or existing
bowlers of all ages or ability or
welcome the for rent facility is
available at any time that the ledger
center is open cocaine is available for
anyone wishing to try out or
prior to joining the club the contact
number here is 0 1 26 878 though seven
double eight rochford running club they
meet every tuesday and thursday from Los
well serve them at various location and
the Rochford running club provides
beginners courses and weekly training
sessions for runners of all abilities
it's an opportunity to meet other
runners and have fun while improving
your own running the cost for this is
two pounds if the mobile phone contact
079 double 401 2306 there's yoga on
monday and tuesday evenings and
wednesday and thursday mornings in the
tarsal whole castle road invading
friendly fun and effective yoga courses
for everyone of all abilities you can
contact grateful yogi @ me.com or phone
Oh 1268 double 7 double 3 3 for the six
why mark badminton club the tribe
narrative on Tuesday evening and it's
open to members and invited guests from
half past seven until ten o'clock use
coaching for 12 to 16 year olds is on
Tuesday and Friday
evening from six in the evening to 730
and it's as the David pops sports hall
at the Fitz why mark salling Railly the
club has a home venue of five ports and
is always on the lookout for experienced
players contact Oh 1268 Apple 719 one
for a new furniture reuse center has
opened in rayleigh taking in and selling
affordable quality deafened hand
furniture the hope works reuse center
tape stream donation to stranger and
electrical appliances that can then be
sold on to the general public those
receiving certain benefits are able to
buy at a discounted price hope work then
works in partnership with other
organizations to help families that's
growing desperate need of furniture to
furnish their property hope works also
provides a free of charge collection
service for donations within the
rayleigh area that this defense these
items going into landfill and helps the
environment a delivery service is also
available sat larger items of furniture
to nearby areas anyone is welcome to
come along on browse in the warehouse at
33 book road book load industrial estate
rayleigh and floating timers telephone
0126
simmer for 3 2 3 2 a number of choirs
from across the Rockford district has
joined forces for a special performance
of Carl Jenkins the armed man this very
special performance will take place at
the crisp Pavilion on the 11th of
November at 3pm with the aim of raising
as much money as possible for help for
heroes and the Royal British Legion
tickets are available by calling 0170
235 double 135 do you want to join a
brand new singing group serving hot key
hawk will and holdrege if so the Triple
H community choir maybe for you aimed at
all age ranges and singing abilities the
choir meets on Monday evenings between 7
45 and 8 15 p.m. at hot curry and Hawk
or Methodist Church each session costs
two pounds for more details call 07 5 8
13 90 double four eight council
committee and community forum dates
these meetings are all held at the Civic
sweet really and they are all held at
seven thirty in the evening the west
community forum is on tuesday the 6th
november executive committee wednesday
is seven
development committee Thursday the
twenty-second of November review
committee Tuesday the fourth of December
and the executives Wednesday the fifth
of defender for more information contact
member services on 0 1 702 318 140
rayleigh christmas lights switch-on
event will be on thursday the 29th
november between four-thirty and 630pm
so please note the high street will be
closed at crown hill from 145 p.m. and
the hotkey christmas lights switch-on
event is on saturday the 24th of
November through October we have held
special events that have offered various
recycling collection points around the
district if you've missed out on the
events you can still recycle small
electrical items textiles and clothing
all year round you can recycle your
textiles in the recycling bank and by
using the essex text royal blue bag
curbside collection scheme for further
information or to get some food bags
hole or 800
787 line 07 one small electrical items
can be taken to the recycling bank in
that Lane can talk rochford or the
recycling center in Castle Road in rainy
now can we ask you a question have you
ever been in a hurry to get somewhere
but being stuck behind a slow-moving
waste collection vehicle well how did
you feel annoyed frustrated angry
although it may seem like an
inconvenience please remember the waste
collectors are just trying to do their
job the cancer is constantly working
with our waste contractors fee to the UK
to improve the way they operate
collections across the district however
there are a few things residents can do
to help too please be considerate
impatient when driving behind or
overtaking a working waste collection
vehicle find it when overtaking please
do it slowly and cautiously please be
aware of operatives not only working at
the rear of the vehicle but alongside
and crossing the road
although you may see them they may not
necessarily have seen you on collection
day prevent lucky access to roads when
parking your vehicle he is considered
that the collection vehicles need much
more space to maneuver than a collar if
your vehicle blocks the road it may mean
that the bins can't be emptied keep
pathways as clear as possible to allow
sufficient access tube in to ensure the
operative can carry out their jobs
efficiently and in the bin please don't
place any hot ashes into your bins any
ashes must be hold before being cased in
the non-recyclables bin and please don't
case any large or heavy objects such as
furniture or carpet into your bins large
or heavy objects can be taken to the
castle road recycling center in rayleigh
or may be able to be connected via the
council's chargeable bulky waste
collection service the normal
recyclables bin is for household waste
only that means no commercial or
industrial waste and if you want to book
bulky waste collection you can call /
170 2318 triple one or visit www.flu.gov
UK /recycling
see in it to win it without to special
competitions digital zoom level
certainty my running through great
competitions you can enter to be in with
a chance of winning style priorities for
young people across the district there's
a way of next competition jayma summer
next to recycle dragon has been busy
digital interesting places around the
watch the district at each place he's
visited he gets the special sticker with
electronic children can take part in the
competition by following in mexic paw
prints all you have to do is pick up a
competition recent visit the places
nexus thing up for the questions on the
form and write down the letter that's on
the sticker when you have all the
letters on the leaflet rearrange them to
spell out the prize word once you've
worked out what the word is sent in your
entry form and you could be a winner
among the prizes on offer a family day
parties to a local Leisure Centre
first-ever collective the politician is
designed to be a fun day out for the
family to go and explore some of the
beautiful natural historical and
cultural sites to watch the district has
to offer as well as learning more about
recycling is an air competition form
online at www our hwk forward slash
restart clean competition through your
school from libraries within the
district or from the council reception
areas in rochford enrollee completed
imprints should be sent to recycling got
repeal offices staff speed rochford
ethics SS for one BW and
the council have also lost a class is a
competition display this the sticker in
your car windows that if it's spotted
your vehicle registration will be
entered into a prize draw stickers are
available for great whites in library
hotkey library whole bridge library very
library and Rochford library props the
district council reception areas in both
rock solid and rayleigh for further
information 1001 702 318 one double one
emails customer services at red dots
Gulf Coast UK or website www watch food
rot scoffs UK slang words fresh
restarting competition new way to have
your say the council has developed a new
way for you to tell us what you think of
our services we want to know what you
think of the services we provide so if
you contact us then we'll ask you to
have your say and tell us what you think
of the service you've received and
here's how it works cited to face four
times a year will conduct interviews and
surveys in Council reception areas the
survey will ask you why you visited the
council and whether your expectations
were met in terms of how satisfied you
are with the outcome of your inquiry and
how well the council assisted you with
your enquiry you can also request to be
contacted by a council officer after
being surveyed on a specific issue if
you don't have time to do an interview
then post cars will be left on reception
desks for you to provide comments
telephone and post
you'll still have the opportunity to
take part in phone surveys if you
contact us by phone or you can simply
write to us and let us know what you
think of the service you've received
from us online if you want to leave a
comment about a web page you can do so
by clicking on the logo and completing
the online form stating whether you
found the information you were looking
for and providing an opportunity to
leave further feedback any specific
comments will be forwarded to the
relevant service area as they come in
and emails if you receive an email from
remember staff it will include the have
your say logo simply click on the logo
and complete the online form asking you
to rate the service provided in the
email an opportunity to give further
feedback will be provided did you know
the council has customer service
telephone lines that have been specially
designed to put you through to the right
people as quickly as possible so you can
get answers to your questions the team
has many years of experience and Magnus
have knowledge about local services that
throws the area itself which we hope
will get to the answers you need quickly
efficiently and with the minimum of fuss
the staff are friendly and want to help
they don't work from a script and they
are a single point of contact for most
questions you might have about the
council and its services the system
that's in place has also been set up
because we want to try and be able to
answer your questions with one telephone
we don't want to have to ask you to
bring back or ask if we can ring you
back we know many people find is
frustrating we will give you telephone
numbers for all the different ways to
customer services team to help and the
council services they cannot answer
questions about so whether it's an
inquiry about your recycling collection
abandoned vehicles or any of the dozens
of other services the council looks
after then don't hesitate to give us a
call don't forget you can also visit the
council's offices in South Street
between eight-thirty and 5 30 or 5 p.m.
on fridays and the rayleigh civic street
unlocked eros rayleigh between 8am and
five-thirty p.m. or five o'clock on
Fridays to us that you're to ask your
questions the council is also
continuously updating its website with
information as well as news and events
so don't forget you can also log on to
www.nasa.gov numbers that you need the
customer services team 10 170 2318
triple one they will deal with refuse
and recycling bulky household collection
pest control environmental health
solution noise bonfires food contain
tree preservation orders woodlands and
trees hearts and open spaces abandoned
vehicles stray animals
streetlights and recruitment customer
services team two is on over 170 2318
191 they deal with Channing planning
enforcement building control lounge
charges cemeteries housing advice and
homelessness and leisure activities the
email address customer services at
Rochford dot dot dot uk' the office
opening hours are from 832 530 monday to
thursday and 8 30 25 or friday there's a
special line for council tax and benefit
inquiries 0170 23 18 19 7 or 8 the main
switchboard is 0 17025 463 double 6 and
they'll deal with all other inquiries
from other useful numbers the recycling
company that deals with all the rubbish
in rockford is called cita and their
number is 0 17025 double 3 double 80 and
you can call them if for any reason your
bin has not been emptied on any beat
watch the closing Association is on Oh
800 Oh 12 1991
essex county council highways they deal
with gritting dropped kerbs broken
manholes potholes and trees on grass
verges you can get them on 0845 60 376
31 essex county council recycling center
for household waste in Castle Road the
disposal helpline is great for 5603 7625
you might want the Citizens Advice
Bureau at some time you can get them on
08 double 44 double 70 80 8 and for any
out-of-hours emergencies the number is 0
1 2 6852 7317 a first look at 21 a
census data the census of england and
wales took place on the twenty-seventh
of march 2011 the headline results have
just been released which contain a great
deal of information about the district
if it's just a first release of data
with the next release scheduled for
November will keep you in touch and what
it means for the district and the
council the key information for the
district from this first releases a
release of data is compared to the 2001
census the total population of rocks
that has grown by six point one percent
Roger that now has a population of
eighty-three thousand three hundred in
the 2011 stench this concave the 78,000
483 in 2001 an increase of 4800 of 17
people compared with the 2001 census the
2011 of census reports the three largest
percentage increases in the population
of rupture at all the 60 to 64 year old
1765 additional people 85 + year olds
575 additional people and 80 200 year
old by 553 additional people compared to
the 2001 census the 2011 census reports
the three largest percentage decreases
in the population of Rochford Arbor 30
to 34 year olds 1343 fewer people five
to nine year olds 682 fewer children and
35 to 39 year old 791 fewer people these
are just a few of the headlines
statistics from the first release of
data more information will be released
over the coming months if you want to
find out more detailed information you
can visit the office for national
statistics web site at www.imtcva.org
the council can also help to find
funding for your group did you know that
the council has a special facility in
place that can help organizations such
as community and voluntary groups
thoughts and other clubs schools social
enterprises and small businesses to
search across a huge range of funding
sources for free the council has joined
forces with grants net to provide a
searchable database of funding
opportunities ranging from European
funds through to Lottery awards and
charitable trust grant net is completely
free to use and available by clicking on
the ground search icon at the bottom of
the front page of our website at
www.sec.gov qk alternatively just type
WWE are you shook a forward slash grant
search into the address bar it's a
really simple system to use you just
register your details and obtain a
password in order to search the system
for funds appropriate to your project
the council's community planning officer
Andrew lowing said this is an excellent
service and provides access to a wide
and varied range of funding bodies it
can be time-consuming finding the right
source of funding for your project and
the benefit of this services that it
provides information on the full range
of UK and european union support
provision in a single searchable
database suitable for all types of
organizations for more information or if
you have any questions about grant net
contact Andrew lowing on 0 1 702 318 0 6
1 or you can contact the rail eruption
and district association for voluntary
service they also have
access to grant net in getting touched
read em by calling oh one through six
eight double 7q 796 the annual report
2011-12 Rushford District Council
produces an annual report which gives an
overview of the counsels performance
spending and financial position the full
report is available on our website the
council produces a detailed income and
expenditure account which can be found
in the statement of account and is set
out in a prescribed manner the accounts
show the cost of services in 2011-12
under each of our corporate objectives
and the amount less to define it from
local and national tax income where did
the money actually come from well the
10.5 million that we spend on providing
local services after contributions from
reserves and income raised from various
fees and charges came from local and
national taxes and redistributed
business rates
our total income for the year was 10.33
million which was split 1.14 million in
government grants that equates to eleven
percent of the total 2.79 million from
national business rates returned to the
council that's twenty-seven percent and
6.4 million from council tax from
residents and that it equates to the
remaining sixty-two percent now if you
look at the revenue account surplus for
the years 2011-12 the total income was
10.3 32 million but the total cost of
services with ten points or 54 million
which left us with the deficit for the
year 122,000
now the council is using balances suit
up over previous years to cover some of
the reduction in government funding the
council recognizes that these balances
won't last and have challenged to
continue to reduce expenditure
the council was responsible for
collecting for 7.7 million pounds of
council tax last year but we only kept
fixed web forming equivalent to 30 MP in
every town collective the maturity of
what's collected is paid to others essex
county council received 30 4.1 million
if it's great Authority 4.1 million
Essex spiral thority to appoint one
media and the parish town councils 1
million capital expenditure we also
spend money on improving land and
buildings and also continue delivering
excellent cost effective services for
all our customers total expenditure is
the money spent on the purchase and
improvement of building us vehicles
equipment and plenty of software if you
fall cabbage expenditure as it results
in athletes which the council and the
community can Eunice for more than one
year level expenditure does not directly
affect the council text not was spent in
thousands of vehicles and equipment 231
salesman alright cemetery extension
22,000 measure implies definitive
129,000 5x sexual renewal grants 36,000
to save up the thirties bronze 261,000
peyote in Orchestra just 31,000 thankful
property is 390 2010 state way energy
streams 104,000 and the total was twelve
hundred and sixteen thousand some of the
projects not completed in 2011-12 will
be roll forward into 2012-13
discretionary rates relief charities and
some sports clubs are entitled to eighty
percent mandatory relief on their
business rates in order to provide
additional support the council can award
discretionary relief for the remaining
twenty percent before relief is normally
awarded to organizations representing
Scouts guys or youth activities the
provision of welfare in the community
and the provision of village or
community hall and is also available for
eligible sports club the 2011-12
discretionary relief was awarded to 46
organizations throughout the district at
a cost of twenty four thousand six
hundred pounds for the council
delivering value for money during
2011-12 the council has been successful
in generating income through the
provision of services to partners and
other councils and approximately a
hundred seventy thousand pound has been
owned from these initiatives the council
also delivered savings during the year
1.4 million this has been achieved by
more efficient service and better
organization council staff are working
harder than ever to ensure it office its
residents value for money the council is
determined to deliver high levels of
performance what should have shown that
despite having one of the lowest
government grant funding levels it
continues to save money and reduce
spending we will continue to keep close
scrutiny over council money the
financial performance rochford district
council is among the best in the country
when it comes to collecting council tax
the revenues and benefits team collected
98.7 percent of the forty seven point
six million pound counts
text to last year it was 98.9 percent in
2010-11 we also collected 96.7 percent
of fifties rates to you last year
compared to ninety six point eight
percent in 2010-11 collecting income in
the current economic client is
challenging but staff has offered as
much support and advice as possible to
help local residents and businesses to
pay their bills how to beat the burglars
most burglaries and break-ins are
preventable to serve two burglars get in
through a door and a third through a
window so proper security is vital there
are a few simple steps you can take to
set include as a challenge and avoid
becoming a victim of crime fit front and
back doors with good quality locks lock
external doors and windows when you die
out and use timers for lights and radios
when it gets dark or you're away lock
all upvc doors correctly I'm lifting the
handle and using the key keep doors
locked even when at home fix window
locks to all easy to reach windows for
example hose on the ground floor above a
flat roof or near a drainpipe but
remember at least one window in each
room on the first floor or above must
have a means of escape fit a burglar
alarm invest in well positioned motion
sensitive security lighting keep all
keys especially car keys out of sight in
the house and well away from doors and
windows keep jewelry out of sight
ideally in a safe
not in a jewelry box in the bedroom
that's the first place the bird level
look lock all ladders and gardening
tools in a secure shed or garage leave
them lying about in the garden and you
make it easier for the burglar to attack
your home so watch the district
Community Safety Partnership the CST is
urging drivers to spare a thought for
other people before they part care less
than antisocial on-street parking
represents a serious trouble to a
pedestrian especially those in
wheelchairs or those with a visual
impairment it can also present a hazard
to motorists by denying them a clear
view of traffic the law regards the
pavement as part of the highway and any
vehicle blocking it to the extent that a
pedestrian wheelchair Calla path is
deemed to be creating an obstruction and
that could leave the driver facing a
fixed penalty fine
parking on the pavement even if the
vehicle is only harmful creates
unnecessary obstacles for pedestrians
it's especially hazardous for elderly
and disabled people only parents with
pushchairs and buggies it could force
them into the road and into danger so
please show a little consideration and
think about the impact your actions
could have on others before you park
courtesy costs nothing and put save you
the cost of a fine deck and depression
help people suffering from mental health
problems are almost five times as likely
to have severe decks compared to other
whales that's the finding 48
moneysavingexpert.com poll to determine
a scale of the problem of mental health
and debt the research shows that just as
mental health problems can cause death
so debt worries also cause mental health
issues such as depression and anxiety
moneysavingexpert.com has put together
mental health & Dec afraid I've the
sufferers and their carers written with
guidance from several million charities
it includes help from where to find free
one-to-one deck calcium working with
banks and how friends and care is to
help perfect I've next is also available
at www.sec.gov docu k district manager
of Rochford and rayleigh citizeness
applies below so Murray said many people
suffering with mental health issues find
a means of debt
difficult we encourage people not to
ignore do it but seek shelter soon as
possible the earlier they are dealt with
the better the best thing to do is to
contact one of the nonprofit
organizations offering free better price
listed in the booklet local CA be
contact details also in the booklet they
will guide you as to what to do and they
be able to liaised if creditors on your
behalf the contact details for national
organization is unlisted on page 16 of
the booklet if that's too much for you
right now and you have a trusted friend
at least talk through this guide the
pocket can be downloaded from
www.zawya.com forward slash mental
health please be aware that it is a fit
file then make a print download Rochford
district matters is designed and
published by oxford district council its
editor it's a trip john the telephone
number for the council is 0 1 702 546
366 the magazine is printed by Morton
print--limited 01 50 75 2 3 4 5 6 and
that brings us to the end of this
edition which was recorded by volunteers
from the rayleigh roxford and castle
point talking newspapers for the blind
at their studio in rockford